a car chases pretty well it was crazy
why would you rob a bank in the busiest
part of LA at rush hour the diamond
shaking rush hour what are you doing
dumbest [ __ ] what are you doing this guy
robbed a bank and then got stuck in
traffic
yeah he would have been idiot he
would've been better off robbing that
Bank and going into the to the Metro
like the subway yeah cuz everyone
forgets there's a subway in LA and yeah
[ __ ] disgusting yeah no one wants to
use it you could just walk down those
stairs and the police would've been like
yeah yeah I'm is my break right now so
we haven't gone into the underworld and
many decades that I mean like just weird
seeing it this helicopters following
this guy there live-streaming the whole
thing which is sick which is first of
all [ __ ] sick it's funny it's crazy
how like shareable that [ __ ] is our
buddies like it was a car chase and
immediately all of us are on that [ __ ]
like just like taxing about it oh [ __ ]
crazy turn he's going the wrong way in
the four or five holy [ __ ] and the news
is loving that [ __ ] yeah it's just like
watching a episode of [ __ ] Hot Wheels
yeah Cody thank you for the bits
wonderful reporting guys keep it up uh
yeah and then these dudes they they hit
a car and crashed in downtown and took
off on foot and then he tried to [ __ ]
carjacked another person i ta ya he like
pointed like a I think it a gun Simon
had a gun in the window was like let me
get your car the person just drove off
yeah he's like for me and so he started
running he thought was gonna be easier
yeah and then eventually just got
absolutely tackled by the cops such a
hilarious thing you're just assuming the
car doors unlocked yeah I know that's
those like the first thing you do yeah
you get in the car just just yep come on
come on open up man come on it's like a
Ford Fusion
there's no I mean there's no amount of
money that they got that could have been
worth a bank robber right now banks
don't even have a lot of money like on
hand I know
it's like I don't know it's like quarter
mil half a mil no but that's like in
this safe isn't it yeah it's like
sweating the ceiling you know I don't
even know like what knows it teller like
it's like 20 grand max yeah I mean I
guess that's pretty good for what no but
it's like I'm in there 45 seconds you
get 20 grand no it's like separated in
drawers and stuff and like locked away
it's like you only ever keep like 5
grand maybe in your top drawer or like -
did anyone rob your bank when you were
there no it happened before really
yeah I thought you were scared that it
would happen like no really I talked
about this because of the robbery they
put double pane glass
oh yeah the dudes came in with a with a
like a SMG why yeah it was like some
like real like like a real ass robbery
yeah and that's crazy
it was two of them but was funny was
they were robbing the [ __ ] plate well
first of all they pull up and they have
the gun that our personal banker is his
first [ __ ] day on the job or like
this first week yeah he's like yeah dude
watch me happy
yeah mashed up and at that point the the
bank didn't have any mmm double pane
glass okay I was like older so they just
hopped over with the gun and they were
like give us the money
this teller apparently that was working
there as she stood she like wants to be
a hero know what she's like no I'm not
giving the money my branch manager was
like here's the money yeah she was like
give him the money she's like no she's
like give insurance will cover it it is
fine give him the [ __ ] money so after
she like gets firm with her she starts
to give the money and it like just like
straight out of like some Batman [ __ ]
like 1950s Batman cartoon they're
they're the bag they used there's a hole
in it no way they're putting money in it
was falling out of the bag I didn't even
realized was falling out of the bag but
this if you could have come better
prepared you've had a commit like some
[ __ ] federal felony and you you come
with that you come with a bag with a
hole you think someone would have
checked someone at some point all right
gear check all right gun check mask
check
adidas check teeth by by the way
yeah those things are sight sick shell
toe fire what else we forget what else
good masks
yo need that we got ok we got masks cool
we're good they're just as they're
pulling up oh we forgot the [ __ ] bag
I mean I got this 7-eleven yeah exactly
dude exactly all right man yeah better
than nothing yeah they've gone in and
then they took the money and then they
dipped and then I don't think they ever
got caught really cuz our freeways our
branch was right by a freeway okay so it
was easy just like hop on and like
you're gone damn that's cursed like
after that they put the double penguin
and I guess that's a thing like some
banks like not all of them but like you
can assume that some of them like when
they put in the double pane glass it's a
it's because it's been robbed really
it's like a reactionary thing huh yeah
it's like this risk is proven so they
they add it yeah that's crazy that they
owe banks they stink yeah dude is this
just like a political conversations no
no no thanks man
they stink suck not even like it
actually smell yeah working thanks stink
yeah okay because this is the money
thank you money stinky money and like I
saw the song was but I just you're just
locked in that [ __ ] David Blaine cube
yeah with three other people and busting
ass just me and this other dude working
oh man it was just us two and like the
only like I mean the a/c is supposed to
work in there but it doesn't yeah yeah
did someone ever come in and was like I
want to deposit a million bucks
I mean it was a crazy what's the crazy
[ __ ] that happen the literal like a
literal crazy [ __ ] like old people shat
themselves in the bank what yeah yeah
like to be sitting there like waiting
for someone to pick them up they just
[ __ ] themselves didn't they get what
would they do
just someone had to clean it up so
that's the craziest [ __ ] that's ever
happened literally the craziest [ __ ]
yeah let me out dude [ __ ] and piss
himself they just got up and walked out
nah man like his son or whatever can't
picked him up but he I was like dude ooh
oh my god that's like sad and funny at
the same time they brought someone in to
clean it up for this like he's so old
plugin
we're back to poop yeah back to poop uh
uh I'm probably the craziest transaction
I got skimmed what's that mean I have
like a dude put someone else's debit
card number on another card okay and
like the card name matched his face okay
and you like drew all the money out no
way yeah I could point him out you got
robbed I got robbed yeah that's crazy I
could point him out in a line it
happened like on like my second-to-last
day really I was so funny how did you
know um
my branch manager like like told me like
what no actually I think was in my last
week cuz it was basically I remember
like it was like leading up to my last
day like she had just like [ __ ] had
it with me like I was always [ __ ]
some [ __ ] up like a lexapro like just
halves and out like wonderful wooden
wares and so yeah and like I remember
her just being like it's it's fine
like you're leaving it doesn't even
matter there's really nothing to say
here bud so what happens in that
scenario do they get there like as the
bank compensate the person definitely
right because yeah thanks fault like
there's like some investigation and they
like look at the tapes and I definitely
gave him the money how much was it three
grand
that's still yeah still pretty good
payday yeah that's good payday walk into
a bank just [ __ ] trick them into
giving you 3 grand
I know every dough he picked the perfect
dude yeah you own half Zach yeah half
asleep on half sands depressed okay I
get 10 grand yeah sure man that'll be
like four bucks ten um what's your name
Steven nice to meet you did yes I'm all
right
on the first bill ldap through the glass
then one time yeah we enjoy that bro
yeah it'll copy some nice a diamond yeah
let me know how it works out this
awesome
[Music]
it's a dozen club these are custom pump
these are Dustin phone these are dust